Think about a time you crumbled under
pressure. Maybe you froze during a
wedding speech, hit the wrong note on
stage, or stumbled through a job
interview. We all have a story like
that. I want you to keep yours in mind
while you watch this video. Because
today, we're going to share a few
strategies on how to handle those
moments better. How to perform well even
when the stakes are high. But before we
get there, we need to understand why we
fall apart in the first place. What's
happening in the brain when you're doing
something you've practiced a thousand
times and everything suddenly goes
sideways? To answer that, I want to
introduce you to someone. Her name is
Cate Campbell. In 2008, Cate was a young
Australian swimmer who made her debut at
the Beijing Olympics. Here she is coming
in third in the 50-m freestyle with a
time of 24.17
seconds.
She was one of the youngest swimmers
there. Her career was off to a
swimmingly good start. In 2012, Cate
competed in the Summer Olympics in
London, where she won a gold medal with
her team. She was crushing it. Then, it
was the Australian Swimming
Championships. Cate won the 100-m
freestyle.
Here she is weighing in on her
performance.
And I'm very pleased with that's what I
did. I feel like I'm fighting fit again,
which is really nice. Um that's the
first time I've personal best since I've
been in 3 years, which is very
encouraging. Her next stop, the 2016
Summer Olympics in Rio.
Cate came in with sky-high expectations.
Now, I'm not a gambler, but if I was,
I would have put my money on her winning
the 100-m freestyle. She reached the
finals. She was placed in lane four. The
best swimmers are usually placed in the
middle of the group.
Here's the starting lineup.
Pay close attention to what happens next
because nearly everything important in
this race
happens before it even begins.
Cate is here in the yellow swim cap.
Okay, they're off. Cate shoots off like
a rocket. By the time she hits the 50-m
mark, it looks like Olympic gold medal
predictions were too conservative. She's
on pace for a world record, but then
Cate didn't come in first, or second, or
third.
She didn't even end up in fourth or
fifth place.
She came in sixth.
Cate herself calls this the greatest
choke in Olympic history. So, what
happened? How did a skilled athlete
poised to take home the gold bungle
something that looked like it was in the
bag? The question is,
why? It turns out there's a complex
psychology behind this all-too-common
experience. A few key factors come into
play. The first, working memory. I mean,
I think about our working memory is like
our cognitive horsepower, right? It
allows us to get lots of things done,
juggle numbers in our head, plan for the
future, make decisions based on a lot of
different information. That's Sian
Beilock. She's a cognitive scientist.
She has spent years studying the
phenomenon of choking under pressure.
Working memory is all the stuff you keep
in your head as you're doing a task.
Sian and her colleagues have a fun
experiment to show how this aspect of
our memory works. Let's give it a try.
I'm going to briefly show you a list of
digits on your screen. Your job, repeat
them back to me. Ready? Here we go. 7 6
2 4
Got it?
In just a moment, these numbers will
disappear. Bye-bye, numbers.
Okay, now say the numbers back to me.
Let's see how you did.
You probably got it, right?
So, let's make it a little more
complicated.
Same experiment, but this time
we'll bump it up to six numbers.
Ready?
5 8 9
7 4 3
Take a moment, memorize them.
They're about to disappear.
Okay, now is your time to shine. Say the
numbers back to me.
Here they are again.
How did you do this time?
A little more challenging? Now, we're
really going to go nuts.
It's still six numbers.
9 1 0 4 8 2
I even give you a little more time to
memorize them this time.
Okay, numbers go poof.
Now, I want you to repeat the numbers
back to me.
But in reverse order.
How'd that go?
Much harder, right?
Here's how I'm doing it in my head. I
think of the whole series, and then I
ask myself what the last number is.
Then, I try and remember the whole
series from start to finish again, and
pick out the second last number. And so
on. It's tough.
Your ability to hold the numbers in your
head as you're coming up with the
answers is the product of your working
memory.
As you can see, we don't have vast
reserves of working memory. What happens
when our limited working memory is
occupied with something we shouldn't be
focused on?
We choke.
That's what happened to Cate Campbell,
the Olympic swimmer with the quote
"greatest choke in Olympic history."
Let's take a closer look at that race
again.
We're back on the starting blocks. Cate
is in lane four, yellow cap.
The referee tells the athletes to take
their marks.
This is the moment Cate lost the race.
Did you see it?
No?
Let's take another look.
Slower this time.
Pay attention.
The referee tells the athletes to take
their mark.
And right there, if you zoom in closely,
you might notice Cate made a slight
movement.
One small flinch.
It was barely perceptible.
Barely perceptible, that is, to everyone
except Kate.
Kate worried that this tiny flinch would
be considered a false start.
At this moment, her attention shifted.
Instead of focusing her working memory
on swimming the race the way she had
planned, she started thinking, "Oh no, I
made a mistake. They're going to
disqualify me."
The race started. She dove into the
water. She started swimming.
But her mind was still on that flinch.
She actually swam the first 50 m too
fast. That's why, by the time she made
the turn, she was way ahead of world
record pace.
But she was also running out of gas.
Instead of being able to accelerate on
the way home, she lost steam. Soon,
other swimmers were passing her.
It can also be helpful to see how
deploying your working memory
effectively can help you in a stressful
situation. We're on the basketball
court. It's a game between the Golden
State Warriors and the Los Angeles
Lakers.
Here's Steph Curry, number 30, crushing
it as usual. He effortlessly passes it
to Jonathan Kuminga, almost as if he
knew exactly where his teammate was
behind him.
Kuminga snakes his way through the other
players like Moses parting the sea. I
don't know about you, but if it was me
on the court,
I would have a hard time even dribbling
the ball, much less figuring out who to
pass it to.
Much less passing it to someone I can't
even see.
How did Steph do it?
Okay, fine. He's a basketball genius.
I'm not.
But this is also about working memory in
action. Skilled players have seen so
many similar situations on the court,
they don't need to expend a lot of
working memory trying to remember where
everyone is. They can process the game
faster. They can focus their their
memory on the elements of the situation
that are truly novel. An opposing player
unexpectedly stealing the ball, for
instance.
Steph has played so much basketball that
he's able to take in lots of things that
you and I would need to process more
slowly. We're thinking through
everything. It's slow. It's
time-consuming.
He's using muscle memory. It's fast,
quick. The same thing happens to you
when you do something you've done a
thousand times before, like drive to
work. You're listening to music or
chatting on the phone. You're not even
thinking about navigating the traffic.
And then, bam, you're in your parking
spot at work. There's another dimension
to choking. It has to do with anxiety.
Sian and her colleagues ran another
experiment. They brought people into the
lab to have their brain scanned.
Some of the people were anxious about
doing math.
Others, not so much.
Then they had people look at a screen
and told them that a math problem would
occasionally pop up.
Before it did, they'd give a little
advance warning. A yellow square would
pop up. Let's give it a try.
I'm going to show you a series of
questions on your screen. Occasionally,
a math problem will show up. You'll see
a little yellow square before it does.
How did you feel when you saw the
square?
In Sian's study, people who liked math
were fine. But the people who worried
about their math skills, when they saw
the yellow square, certain areas of the
brain lit up.
Areas associated with pain. This was
true even before they were doing any
actual math. They simply knew it was
coming, and the pain part of the brain
was activated. And we've shown this for
students taking tests, especially
students who are really nervous and
anxious about how they're going to do on
the test. We've shown that actually just
getting them to reinterpret what they're
feeling leads to better performance.
Instead of focusing on the problem, they
were now focused on the fact that they
didn't think they would be able to solve
the problem.
The volunteers were not using their
working memory to solve the math
problem. They were using their working
memories to remind themselves that they
were not good at math.
There's another way that anxiety can
make us choke.
Let's say you had to read something out.
It's a simple line of text and you get a
practice as much as you like beforehand.
Should be easy, right? Well, take a look
at what happened back in 2009. US
Supreme Court Chief Justice John Roberts
was swearing in President-elect Barack
Obama.
Both men had spent years in the public
eye dealing with difficult situations.
They had ample time to practice. The
words were not complicated.
I, Barack Hussein Obama, do solemnly
swear that I will faithfully execute the
office of the President of the United
States.
Instead,
here's how it went. I, Barack Hussein
Obama, do solemnly swear I, Barack
Hussein Obama, do solemnly swear
that I will execute the office of
President to the United States
faithfully. that I will execute
the off- faithfully the president office
of President of the United States
>> of the United States faithfully. And
will, to the best of my ability,
>> And will, to the best of my ability,
preserve, protect, and defend the
Constitution of the United States.
Preserve, protect, and defend the
Constitution of the United States. So
help you, God? So help me, God.
Congratulations, Mr. President.
What happened? It wasn't a difficult
challenge, but the stakes were very,
very high.
When that internal pressure gauge inside
your head gets into the red zone, things
that you can do in your sleep become
very difficult. In front of all of the
people who are watching, the Chief
Justice and the President-elect started
to focus on the audience and not on the
sentence in front of them.
And once things started to go wrong, I
bet there was a voice inside their heads
that said,
"You're screwing up in front of millions
of people."
Think about the last time you tried to
parallel park. Was anyone watching?
If so, chances are it was much harder to
do.
The stakes are just higher when you're
performing before a crowd.
Sometimes the people around us can make
us choke because we believe that they
believe we're going to mess up. There's
a word for this in the world of
psychology.
Stereotype threat. Researchers find that
if you believe that others hold a
negative stereotype about you, you are
more likely to behave in ways that make
that stereotype come true. Put another
way, the views that other people have of
you can become prophecies that come
true. There was even a movie about this
idea some years ago. It was titled White
Men Can't Jump.
It was about the stereotype that white
players are not as good at basketball as
black players. Have you been in a
situation where you are aware that
others expect you to fail?
If so, you know how easy it becomes for
you to choke.
So, what are the solutions to choking?
What can you do to keep yourself from
freezing up the next time you have a
presentation or a job interview or a big
game? The first thing to do is practice.
Remember Steph Curry on the basketball
court?
Practice helps you become so fluent in
the task that it becomes nearly
automatic. Now, your working memory is
free to focus on what's important. But,
what if you feel really nervous?
The next time jitters set in, instead of
thinking of nervousness as an emotional
state,
try to think of it as a physiological
state.
If you get sweaty palms or feel your
heart is pounding, instead of telling
yourself, "I'm in over my head,
focus on the symptoms and then reframe
them.
Say, "My palms are sweaty. My heart is
racing. That means I must be excited. My
body is getting ready for a challenge."
And myself and other colleagues have
done a lot of work showing that when you
can get people to reinterpret those
symptoms as a sign they're going to
thrive, that beating heart is shunting
blood to my brain so I can think, rather
than a sign they're going to fail, they
actually perform better. Breathing is
also an underrated trick. Not only does
it take your mind off the thing you're
worrying about, it can calm your body in
the process. Here's one final tip for
acing your next performance. Try a
ritual. If you start to pay too much
attention to things that you shouldn't
be focused on, a ritual can help. You
can come up with your own rituals, count
backwards, sing a song, or focus on one
important thought. In moments of
pressure, it can sometimes feel like our
minds are working against us.
But these blocks are not signs of
weakness. They're clues into how our
brains operate and how we might learn to
work with our hidden brains for a better
outcome. If you want to learn more about
how your mind works, please tune into
the Hidden Brain audio podcast. You can
find it on Apple, Spotify, or at
hiddenbrain.org.
I'm Shankar Vedantam.
See you next time.